[MUSIC PLAYING]
CAMILLE MASSEY: What
vision and power
and beauty and talent, Jeremy.
JEREMY MCQUEEN: Thank you.
CAMILLE MASSEY: This is
such a pleasure and an honor
to be here and to have
this conversation with you.
It was several years
ago when we first met,
and you were just starting.
You were just
starting Black Iris.
You had this idea.
You were going out.
You were doing it all on
your own, pushing it forward.
And now, we are
sitting here at Google,
and you are preparing
for the world
premiere of "A Mother's Rite".
Tell us about this journey.
JEREMY MCQUEEN: It's
been full of challenges,
but it's been very
fulfilling in so many ways
that I hadn't even
ever imagined.
I've always loved dancing
and creating my own dances
in my bedroom as a child.
And to be able to see
my work being performed
on stages like the
Kennedy Center,
it's just been very humbling.
CAMILLE MASSEY: And the Kennedy
Center, you mention that,
because that was April 2017.
And I believe a
principal dancer somehow
noticed what you were doing.
How did that happen?
JEREMY MCQUEEN: Misty
Copeland invited us
personally to come
and present "Madiba"
on her program for a week
long at the Kennedy Center.
I recall the day that I got the
email from the Kennedy Center
that they were
considering my work,
and that Misty Copeland
had given them my name.
I actually thought
it was junk mail.
I was sitting down in a
meeting, a very intense meeting,
and I noticed this email that
I had from the Kennedy Center.
And I was like, why am I getting
junk mail from the Kennedy
Center?
I've never even
seen a show there?
How did this happen?
So I just so
happened to open it.
And it said something
along the lines of,
your ballet about Nelson
Mandela at the Kennedy Center
for a week live orchestra.
And I was just like, I
immediately started crying.
I hadn't even finished
choreographing the ballet yet,
and there was already a lot
of buzz about what I was doing
and the change that I've
been trying to make.
So it was really
rewarding and so humbling
that Misty Copeland was so
generous to recommend me
for this opportunity.
CAMILLE MASSEY: And
so you've been there
at the Kennedy Center,
and then you're
going to be at Marcus Garvey
Park, which is free and open,
1600 seats.
Hopefully, filling many
of those, if not all.
And so part of your
mission is about audience
and about who you bring in.
But before we get
to that, I just
want to ask you more
about "A Mother's Rite"
and how that came about.
I had the pleasure of seeing the
rehearsal at the Bronx museum,
and there was a moment
when a woman stood up
from the audience during
the Q&A, and said,
you've told my story to you.
Which she then went on to say
that her son had been killed.
And how do you work to
create a project that
has that kind of effect?
JEREMY MCQUEEN: I'm not sure
I know the answer to that.
Guts, I guess, a lot of faith
and trust in my journey.
"A Mother's Rite"
was something--
one of my composition
teachers, Kazuko Hirabayashi,
who has been a mentor
to me for many years,
always wanted me to
use Rite of Spring.
As part of our
college courses, she
was like, why don't you try
choreographing to this music?
And I was like, no way.
Are you kidding me?
So many choreographers
have choreographed to it.
The most iconic of
levels, and the music
is extremely complicated to
hear, to count musically,
and so I just always
pushed it away.
But at this point
in my career, I
started to feel like I
wanted to push myself.
I feel like the
only way that we can
grow as individuals
is if we put ourselves
in uncomfortable positions.
And so just looking at
the music and listening
to the intonation
of the melodies
and how sharp and strong certain
moments were in the music,
and then also thinking
about black culture
and black history
today, I was trying
to find a way to connect
the two things together.
And as I started to
dig a little bit more
into the original story for Rite
of Spring, which was a ritual
sacrifice within a
pagan Russian village,
I started to see a little
bit of similarities
within the sacrifices
that are happening
within the black community
not necessarily willingly,
but the sacrifices
of the mothers
essentially turning a new
leaf and taking on a new life
as a champion for their
sons and daughters
that have been
killed senselessly.
CAMILLE MASSEY: And
there's certainly
a lot to be mad about
in this society.
But Courtney
Celeste Spears talks
about the power and the
strength of the mother,
but also anger was a component.
JEREMY MCQUEEN: Absolutely.
CAMILLE MASSEY: And I heard you
mention Solange in the concert,
right to be mad.
JEREMY MCQUEEN: Yeah.
CAMILLE MASSEY: How
did that affect you?
JEREMY MCQUEEN:
So the day, I want
to say it was the day
before my boyfriend
and I went to the
Solange concert
at Radio City Music
Hall, I had a sit
down with an advisor of mine.
And we talked about
this ballet that I
had been developing and working
on for about six months prior.
And it originally started
out as a chess game, kind
of a white versus
black sort of thing,
but I really wanted to put
it in a chess game format,
so that we could see all
the characters and players
within these two sides.
But we were having
this conversation,
and he was just like,
something's missing here.
It doesn't feel like we're
pushing culture forward.
It doesn't feel revolutionary
or unique and different.
And so he challenged
me to take a moment
to sit back and dig
a little bit deeper.
And I'm so grateful that I did.
I went to the Solange concert
that night with my boyfriend.
And I like to engulf myself
in whatever experience
that I'm in.
So a lot of my work is
either inspired by something
that I'm going through or
just the observations of those
around me.
And so I was really captivated
by how people were so engulfed
in Solange and her concert.
I mean, people were taking
pictures and videos.
And for me, it was like, OK.
There are attention's
here on her.
What do people that go
to the Solange concert,
how can they connect with her?
And they were really
connected to a moment
that she was having a
nervous breakdown onstage.
She has this song called Mad.
And she talks about, I've
got the right to be mad.
And she kept saying that
over and over and over again.
I started to look around.
I started to think,
you know, what do we
have the right to be mad about?
And I started to think about
the senseless killings of men
and women, but more
specifically about the mothers
and how we often don't get to
hear their side of what they're
going through.
We often hear them talking
about what has happened,
and they are fighting for
justice for their child.
But we don't often get to
see that grieving process.
So this new ballet, it evaluates
a number of stages of grief.
And the ballet starts when
the mother is coming home
from the final court trial where
she finds out the gentleman
was acquitted of all charges.
And so it's that process of,
OK, now the cameras are gone.
We've moved on to
the next trial,
but that mother still has
to live with this forever.
And so we get to have a
microscope look at her healing
process and how she
continues to struggle
every day, every hour
with the loss of something
that she can never get back.
CAMILLE MASSEY: And she's
holding that sweatshirt.
JEREMY MCQUEEN: Yeah.
CAMILLE MASSEY: What
meaning does that have?
JEREMY MCQUEEN: The
sweatshirt, for us,
symbolizes her son's presence.
He passed away, or was killed,
in that sweatshirt in our story
that we've created.
And so that's the
last bit of him
that she can still hold on to.
His body is buried, but
that still smells like him.
It just feels like him.
So that was the last
thing she saw him in.
And so she keeps that at
very high symbolism for her.
She keeps it on a couch,
and she constantly
is gravitating towards it.
CAMILLE MASSEY: Well,
we're living at a time
where Black Lives Matter
has become, fortunately,
part of the zeitgeist.
And many people are
working for more justice.
And the Sorenson's Center
for International Peace
and Justice, where I work,
is based at Cuny Law.
And as you know,
some of my colleagues
have been working on the
disproportionate treatment
against communities
of color for conduct
that's not policed in more
privileged neighborhoods,
and are working for
change in a system.
What do you think
that dance, though,
brings that's different?
JEREMY MCQUEEN:
Movement in general,
I think that it provides
a different perspective.
It allows audience members
to be taken on a journey
that perhaps they would
not otherwise get to see.
We often see and read
articles, or hear
things on the news
about what's going on.
But to be able to see this
being told through movement,
I think is very different and
creative in the sense of it
allows you to feel an emotional
attachment on a greater level
than you would just
reading something.
Being able to see someone
and feel their experience
and see them crying on
stage, to feel that, I think,
is very different than a
two dimensional screen.
CAMILLE MASSEY: I also want
to get in some information
about your other projects.
So Nelson Mandela, we
have an anniversary
of 100 years the day
he was born coming up
this month, next week.
And tell us about
why you chose Nelson
Mandela for a performance.
JEREMY MCQUEEN:
So Nelson Mandela
was one of the world's
greatest leaders.
And it just so happened that
this piece of music, written
by a composer, Carmen
Moore, it just so happened
to fall into my lap.
And it was entitled
"Madiba", and it
was about the story of
Nelson Mandela's life.
Part of the Black
Iris Project's mission
is to not only create
works that reflect
black history or black culture,
but also to promote and elevate
black creative artists.
And so for me to stumble upon
this black classical composer,
and he wrote this amazing
score for a full orchestra,
I immediately was like,
can I sit down with you
and talk about my
idea and my vision?
My vision was always
to create ballets
that reflected
our culture, but I
didn't want to tell stories
that were often commonly told.
Often Black History Month
comes along in February,
we always hear about Rosa Parks
and Martin Luther King Jr,
and certain other
historical figures.
So I wanted this to be
an opportunity for people
to learn a little bit
more about black history
and black culture outside
of Black History Month,
and perhaps stories that
were not commonly told.
So Nelson Mandela
was a figure of that.
For me growing up in middle
school and high school,
I knew very little about him.
And I feel like he was a
very little talked about.
So I was really excited
about the opportunity
to get to share his life journey
on stage through movement.
CAMILLE MASSEY: And that
will also be performed?
JEREMY MCQUEEN: Yes.
So Nelson Mandela
turns 100 years
old on July 18th this year.
And we're really excited
to bring this ballet back
to the city as part of our
August 16th performance.
CAMILLE MASSEY: Great.
Can you give us,
can we kind of delve
into your ambitions and
wishes for the years to come?
JEREMY MCQUEEN: Yeah.
Yeah, of course.
CAMILLE MASSEY: Give
us a peek inside.
JEREMY MCQUEEN: So the next
ballet that we're working on
is a ballet about
Harriet Tubman's life.
CAMILLE MASSEY: Harriet Tubman?
JEREMY MCQUEEN: Harriet Tubman.
My dad passed away
two years ago.
And he owned a large
amount of land in the South
in Alabama, where he grew up.
And so I've inherited that
land along with my mother.
And one of the things that I've
wanted to do for a long time
is find a way to pay tribute
to him and to the land.
And so I thought it'd be
really great to film a dance
film about Harriet
Tubman's life on the land,
so we would actually
go through the woods
and work through the trees.
And hopefully, work with
a steady cam operator.
Our collaborative,
we, of course,
want to create works that
are accessible on stage,
but especially wanting to create
opportunities to allow people
to view our works from the
comfort of their own home,
so that they can still find more
about black history and dance
and ballet and how we
merge them together.
CAMILLE MASSEY: Fantastic.
And a woman, too, and conductor
of the Underground Railroad
and the safe houses through.
Where is the land exactly?
JEREMY MCQUEEN: It's just
outside of Montgomery, Alabama.
CAMILLE MASSEY: OK, where
Brian Stevenson and team
opened the National Memorial
for Peace and Justice.
JEREMY MCQUEEN: Yes.
I'm hoping that there
might be some opportunities
to collaborate
with them as well.
CAMILLE MASSEY: Fantastic.
In the video, you mentioned
some of your seed support
and funders.
And I'm just curious how
you accomplish so much right
now with this small team and
who's supporting your work
and what needs do
you have to grow.
JEREMY MCQUEEN: Definitely
financial needs.
You know, we have been able
to get some seed offerings
from the Rockefeller Brothers
fund and the Ford Foundation,
as well as some
other foundations
that I've poured my heart
out to and shared with them
my mission for social
justice and social equity
or racial equity.
But yeah, we always
need financial support.
As a newer
organization, we are not
eligible for some of the
bigger foundation grants.
You have to have at least
a track record of three
to five years and tons of
reviews and lots of press
and just a proven track
record of success,
and so we're still
building that track record
to get to that point.
So financially, it's
always a struggle.
But I'm always cold emailing
people and meeting people,
out introducing myself.
I feel so strongly
that this is a movement
that we need to have
right now, especially
with the climate that we're in.
Just being able to allow
yourself to experience art
or to even find an
artistic discipline that
allows you to cope and
heal is so important.
CAMILLE MASSEY: As you're
thinking ambitiously,
where do you see yourself
after Marcus Garvey Park?
Are there or outside
of the US as well?
JEREMY MCQUEEN: Yeah.
I would love to take our Nelson
Mandela ballet to South Africa.
I've never been to
South Africa myself,
so I would love to
actually go and see
the historical landmarks that
we feature in our ballet.
I also want the collaborative
to continue to grow and blossom,
and for us to be able to
travel around the country
and the world to be able to
share these ballets that we
create.
Part of our initiative is to
create one new ballet per year.
And so I hope that 20
years down the line,
we'll have 20 ballets of
very diverse background
black individuals that we can
continue to expose and share
with young people.
CAMILLE MASSEY: I'm just
thinking that you also
refer to yourself as an
educator and a performer
as well as a choreographer.
And we've been talking
about your talents
as a choreographer,
but I just want
to take a minute to
talk about your life
as a dancer in "Wicked"
and other performances,
and also as an
educator, because you
have this other big life where
you're inspiring young people
and teaching.
JEREMY MCQUEEN: Well, I started
dancing at a really young age.
My mom was an educator
in the public school
system for 40 years.
And so she taught
English and history.
And from her, I
really understood what
it takes to be an educator.
I saw her learn the floppy disk
drive to the hard scan disk
drive to zip drive
to flash drives.
She's constantly had
to educate herself.
And I've always been so
inspired in the creative ways
that she motivates her students
to keep growing and learning as
well as she grows and learns.
And so I was on
tour with "Wicked".
"Wicked" was one of my
favorite Broadway musicals.
It was my dream show that
I've always wanted to be in.
And I was in
Louisville, Kentucky.
As I was on tour, I would reach
out to different organizations
and just let them
know I was in town.
I love to give back.
I love to teach, and
to go in especially
to communities of color and
just talk about my experience
as a way to motivate
and uplift and encourage
people that might be thinking
about wanting to be performers.
And so in Louisville, Kentucky,
I reached out to the Kentucky
Center where we are performing,
and they gave me a huge plate
of schools to go to.
And I really fell in love
with teaching and giving back
in that city.
And so I feel like all of
these things encompass,
Black Iris Project encompasses
so many things that I love
and so many things that I
believe in from education
to performing to choreography.
CAMILLE MASSEY: Fantastic.
I know we're going to
turn for questions.
But while people are
thinking of their questions,
I'll ask you a last question.
And that is, who inspires you?
You've mentioned your mother.
You mentioned a teacher
earlier, collaborators.
Who comes to mind, either those
you've worked with closely
or others in the world?
JEREMY MCQUEEN: Donald Robinson.
Donald Robinson was a
dance teacher of mine
from seventh grade to
my 12th grade year.
He really taught me
so much about just
being a human being in society.
And I feel like a
lot of the lessons
that he's taught me
have stayed with me even
still today on a daily basis.
One of the lessons that he
taught me was that discipline
is doing what you
know you're supposed
to do even when no one's
there to make sure you do it.
And that has really
stayed with me every day.
I feel like without
his teachings,
I may not be where
I am right now,
because of so much
that he's ingrained
and invested into my life
as well as so many others.
CAMILLE MASSEY: I think your
discipline is so obvious given
all that you've accomplished
in this short time.
Do we have any questions?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Should I
go to the microphone?
CAMILLE MASSEY: Yes, you
can go to the microphone.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Put it down a little bit.
So as you mentioned
earlier, grieving
is often a very private
process that is, unfortunately,
faced on an individual level.
I imagine it's very difficult
to represent that visually
for a broad audience.
You mentioned also
your own experience
with your father passing.
How did you go about researching
how best to represent grief
onstage and respect the
experiences of so many mothers
who, unfortunately, have
had to go through it?
JEREMY MCQUEEN: It's
been a challenge.
We did a lot of research.
Whatever I could do
scholarly in terms
of pulling up
articles or interviews
with different mothers
and trying to find a way
to capture the essence
of their feelings
and based on what they've told
us, but really a lot of it
was looking at the
people closest to me,
so my mother, my boyfriend also.
As I was developing
this whole ballet,
my boyfriend had a
very good friend of his
that was suddenly murdered
just after Thanksgiving.
So to be able to evaluate his
grief process as well as mine
as well as my mother's,
but it's specifically
the people outside of myself,
it really inspired me.
So I looked a lot
about mannerisms.
There's also a
number of articles
that have been done on various
different stages of grief.
And so I started
to read up on that
as well as comparing what stage
of grief I thought I was in
as well as my family members.
But it's been a
very slippery slope.
It's been very nerve
wracking, because I
do want to create
something that's authentic.
The biggest thing for me that I
always try to stress to people
is that it's a
fictional story inspired
by so many different mothers.
I don't know anyone
personally that has
lost a child to police brutality
or racially based violence
in that way.
But in just being respectful
of these different mothers,
I've tried my best
to try to capture
that in an authentic way
by looking at purely nuance
and mannerisms
that can be shared
through movement, because
there's no spoken dialogue.
But as Camille had
mentioned earlier,
there was a mother that
actually came to our preview
at the Bronx Museum
of the Arts, and it
was so rewarding
to be able to hear
her say, I feel like
you've told my story
and in a very authentic way.
She was brought to tears.
She felt like her son's
spirit had brought her there.
What Camille was talking
about the sweatshirt,
she said that she
actually had a sweatshirt
that she kept up on her
mantle for a very long time.
So that was very affirming,
but it's very sensitive.
And we try to be as cognizant
of all of the energies
that we could receive
based on what we're doing.
CAMILLE MASSEY: And in terms
of how you work with a dancer,
with Courtney Celeste Spears
in this piece as the mother,
how did you communicate
with her about grief?
And how did she draw
also on not only
the research that was done,
but on her own experience?
JEREMY MCQUEEN: She
had just lost a friend.
I would say a week after we
started working on the ballet,
she had lost a friend.
And so literally
when it came down
to choreographing the very
beginning of our ballet,
I said, well, when you found
out that your friend had
passed away, what did you do?
We literally walked
through her process of,
OK, so you walked in your house.
What was the first
thing that you did?
And it was really hard for her.
She didn't want to go there at
first, because she was like,
I'm probably going to
break down and cry.
And I just said, OK,
this a safe space.
We always consider the studio to
be safe space and sacred space.
And so we cried.
We cried together.
I, like I said, I evaluated
her journey as well as
the journey of those
around me, and we
tried to piece this
together that way.
CAMILLE MASSEY: More questions?
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
I have a question about
the writing process.
You talked a bit
about your inspiration
and about the music
that inspired you,
about the artist
that inspired you.
I'm curious whether during
the process of rehearsal
working with the dancer or
even through previewing it,
you've made changes to the
story or you've otherwise
introduced adaptations.
JEREMY MCQUEEN: Absolutely.
A big part of choreography
and creation, I think
is the editing process
just like as a writer would
write a book, being able
to look at your work.
We showed it at
the Bronx Museum,
and being able to take a look
and take a step back and say,
OK, what worked?
What didn't work?
One of the things that
we really looked at
was how the story progresses.
Does it progress too fast?
Does the dancer
have enough breaks?
And how can we-- it's 38
minutes, and it's one dancer.
She never leaves the stage.
So in looking at
that process, there
was a lot of stepping back.
We also had a Survey
Monkey that we
did at our first performance, or
our first preview performance,
where we allowed people to
give their feedback written
as well as verbally
to let us know,
how did this make you feel?
Were you uncomfortable?
Were there things that you
wanted to know more about?
Were there things that
you wanted to see less of?
All of that really informed
my process moving forward.
And I think that
by the time we get
to the stage on August 16th, it
will be the fullest and richest
version of what we can present.
CAMILLE MASSEY: Other questions?
While people are
thinking, August 16th
is going to be at 7 PM.
JEREMY MCQUEEN: Yes.
CAMILLE MASSEY: Outside?
CAMILLE MASSEY: Will there
be any kind of talk back,
or is it the two
performances together?
JEREMY MCQUEEN: It's just
the two performances.
So it'll be the Nelson
Mandela work entitled "Madiba"
followed by a brief intermission
and then "A Mother's Rite".
CAMILLE MASSEY: OK, great.
And how many dancers
are involved?
JEREMY MCQUEEN: In the entire
program, there's 17 dancers.
So we're excited.
Our collaborative brings in
professional ballet dancers
from all around the
country that dance
from San Francisco Ballet
to American Ballet Theater
to New York City Ballet.
So it's really great to be able
to have an opportunity for them
to create a tighter
sense of community
amongst the black dancers at
various different companies
as well as being able to share
our works for free or very low
cost.
CAMILLE MASSEY: And I notice you
call it a collaborative rather
than a company.
JEREMY MCQUEEN: Yeah.
CAMILLE MASSEY: And how
do you find dancers?
Or do they find you?
Or is it a combination?
JEREMY MCQUEEN: You
know, it started out
as some dancers
reach out to me now.
They send me their
head shots and resumes.
But it literally started out
as just a group of friends
that never really get to dance
together that we were like,
let's come together.
Let's create some dance.
Let's work.
And--
CAMILLE MASSEY: OK.
Any dancers out there.
JEREMY MCQUEEN:
We're always, you
know, I consider it a
revolving door of dancers.
We're always open to
more people joining,
and it's all based on
the project that we have.
And all these dancers
dance full time
for other companies,
which is why
we call ourselves a
collective or a collaborative.
Because we're a
seasonal organization.
We typically work
during the summer months
when kids need
something to do, so we
want to be an outlet for them
to be able to come and see
some dance.
CAMILLE MASSEY: Great.
Other questions?
It's a shy audience.
Well, while you're
still thinking,
is there something that I
haven't asked you that you
would like to talk about?
I'm curious as how we were
so lucky to get you here
in New York when you're
from California originally.
JEREMY MCQUEEN: Yeah.
So my parents grew
up in the South.
They grew up in Alabama.
And they grew up in
very large families.
And my parents decided that
when they got old enough,
they were going to
move to California.
They wanted to do something
totally different.
They grew up very poor.
And my dad said,
you know, I want
to make my child accessible.
I want him to have
access to all the things
that I didn't have
access to, because who
knows where my
life and my career
could have gone had I been
exposed to things at a younger
age.
So I started playing
music at the age of five.
I played the violin at five.
I carried that all
through high school.
And then I added on the
piano and the flute.
Played for the San Diego
Youth Symphony Orchestra,
but dance and theater was
the biggest passion of mine.
My mom took me to see
"Phantom of the Opera"
on tour when it
came to San Diego.
And I was completely enamored
by the whole experience.
And I looked at my mom, and
was like, I want to do this.
Didn't know I could
make a living doing it,
but I just knew that I wanted
to be a part of that experience
and feel that energy.
Even at eight years old,
sitting on the edge of my seat
with the binoculars
glued to my face,
I really wanted to
keep finding a way
to have that energized feeling.
So naturally, moving
to New York, Broadway,
you know, the capital of
Broadway in the United States,
it was a natural progression.
I attended The Ailey School's
Fordham University college
program, which is a four
year degree program.
And started auditioning
right away after I finished.
So I've been really
grateful and blessed
to have been able to see some
of my wildest dreams come
true in these past 13
years in New York City.
CAMILLE MASSEY: Well, I'm sure
your mentor and your mother
and your father would
have been so proud.
And we're all so proud at
everything you've accomplished.
And we look forward to more.
If you aren't in town in
August, we'll stay tuned.
People can go to your
website, which is?
JEREMY MCQUEEN: Yes.
Blackirisproject.org.
CAMILLE MASSEY: Great.
And we hope to feature
you at the Sorenson
Center at Cuny Law at some
point and other places
during your world tour.
AUDIENCE: I had
one more question.
Do we have time
for one question?
CAMILLE MASSEY: Oh, yes.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Hi.
Thanks for coming.
JEREMY MCQUEEN: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: I was really intrigued
by what your dancer said about
how, you know, for 20 minutes,
there's this lone performance.
Right?
That really can be
uncomfortable, I think,
for some people to watch.
Were there other works
of art that inspired you
in that sounds, like a
performance dance or even
performance art where
it's one performer
really demanding that attention?
JEREMY MCQUEEN: I
had never seen--
I've seen plays with
one person as a child,
but I'd never seen
a dance performance
this long as one person.
Alvin Ailey's "Cry",
it's a very historic,
it was a tribute to his mother.
I think that ballet
is probably somewhere
around eight or nine minutes.
But something of this
length, and then it
kept getting longer and
longer, because I couldn't
do the math apparently.
I would look at, I was trying to
add up the different sections,
and I kept missing things
and missing things.
And then I was like, by the
way, I think this is 40 minutes.
It was terrifying.
It was really terrifying.
I said, who would
want to dance this?
Who would want to be on
stage for 40 minutes long?
But it was just a constant
communication between myself
and the dancer saying,
like, how do you feel?
I remember we did a run through
of the first 12 minutes,
and she was like,
that was 12 minutes?
It felt like four.
So it was a very
collaborative experience.
But, no, I had never seen
anything like it before.
And I think that that's the
reason why I wanted to do it.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thank you.
CAMILLE MASSEY: Great question.
And Courtney really,
when she described
she felt engulfed by
it, I have to say just
watching that performance
that I saw, I really
felt that the whole audience
was engulfed in her,
and it's really a very beautiful
and powerful experience.
So I hope many of
you can see it.
And thank you.
JEREMY MCQUEEN: Thank you.
CAMILLE MASSEY: Bravo.
JEREMY MCQUEEN: Thanks so much.
Well, thank you all for coming.
[APPLAUSE]